azim brought a claim against yorkshire
county cricket club because of racial
discrimination and victimization that he
faced as a whistleblower speaking out
about the racism that he suffered at the
club now that claim has since been
settled with the new chairman of
yorkshire lord patel so today it really
will be about azim explaining to the
parliamentary committee his experience
of racism at the club and why he's
chosen to speak out
does he feel vindicated given that the
claim has been settled
of course he feels vindicated because
not just because the claim has been
settled but because the club has taken
the first important steps towards
creating change at the club implementing
an anonymous whistleblower system to
ensure that no one goes through what
azim went through in raising concerns
about racism within the club this is the
change that he set out to
put in motion by speaking out to make
sure that no one goes through what he
went through so that young british asian
players feel welcomed and supported at
the club and don't suffer what he
suffered and so seeing others feeling
the ability now to speak out after he
has i think is certainly the vindication
that he needs and he will continue to
advocate for change in the sport
did he receive an apology did he receive
a financial settlement
there was a financial settlement and
also an apology made by lord patel the
new york share chairman who said that he
should never have faced
the treatment that he faced he should
never have been treated the way the club
treated him and that the club is very
sorry they apologize to him to and to
his family and have assured him that the
club is going to put in place the
changes that are needed to make the
place more inclusive for everyone in the
sport and i think this is a positive
first step but of course azim will
continue to advocate for the change that
he thinks needs to happen and as we're
hearing with more and more players
coming forward this is a watershed
moment for qriket it's breaking the
silence around racism and hopefully
we'll see positive changes
has he been asked to be part of the
solution when it comes to yorkshire
county cricket club
for now azeem is happy to to let lord
patel take the changes that he needs to
to make and nazim will continue to be
involved in various charities he's
already been announced today as an
ambassador for a mental health charity
he was of course left suicidal and had
mental health issues as a result of the
treatment he faced and so azim will find
a number of different ways uh both
inside and outside of qriket to continue
to advocate for to bring an end to
racism and to be a positive ambassador
for kids coming through the sport
you mentioned the fact that he was
speaking at the select committee later
on today 9 30 covering it live here on
sky news um what do you what can we
expect from that
well this is of course the first public
and independent opportunity um and forum
in which azim will be able to tell his
story i think the public will hear more
about what actually happened uh the
public will hear more about the way the
club treated him the way they tried to
cover this up and the azim really wanted
to resolve this in in an amicable way
and it's really
all of this controversy has happened
because the club didn't listen and do
the right thing and i think it's it's
important that politicians hear this and
that this committee process can be part
of uh pushing for more change in the
sport
um have you worked um on cases like this
in in the past
i've not worked in cases
i've worked with whistleblowers of
course and i've worked with women who
are fighting for change in the sport and
azim i think is really at the forefront
of
um as a whistleblower on racism and
sport and bringing this to the attention
of yorkshire we're now seeing more and
more cricketers come forward and of
course the courage that he's shown in
speaking out is now encouraging others
to do the same so
i you know i hope he you know he won't
be the he will be the first and perhaps
not the last but let's hope that others
will find it easier after what he's been
through
yeah i just wondered what your reaction
was when he came to you and he talked to
you about some of the challenges that he
had faced over a you know considerably
long period of time
my initial reaction was that he he was
someone who was taking a very principled
stance he was motivated by the black
lives matter movement he was devastated
by what had happened to him and he
really wanted to make sure that kids
coming up through the club wouldn't go
through what he went through and that
was his primary motivation throughout
throughout all of this
he wanted to see the changes in the club
that are now starting to happen under
lord patel's leadership and we hope that
that will continue and i really want to
pay tribute to him his courage in coming
forward
he you know it's been a very difficult
year for him he was suicidal when he
left the club because of what happened
he's continued to suffer because of the
attacks that he's faced that we as his
lawyers have faced for bringing these um
complaints forward and it's really a you
know a testament to him and to his
family the support that they've given
him to be able to get through what he's
been through
do you anticipate other cricketers may
well now come forward to you as well at
other clubs um
throughout
not only perhaps the united kingdom but
other parts of the world as well um
feeling emboldened given what we've
heard from azim rafiq
uh already there are cricketers coming
forward with similar stories and not
just in england as you say we've heard
cricketers from essex come forward in
the past few days but i've been
contacted by players in south africa in
india and pakistan this issue and what
azeem has done in speaking out in
breaking this silence is encouraging
people to come out around the world and
talk about their experiences and that
can only be a positive thing for the
game it's important that we create an
inclusive space in all sports in every
aspect of society that people from a
diverse background can succeed and be
supported and that's what i think is so
important about what azeem has done and
the conversation that's now happening in
parliament and around the world and
within the sport and i think azim should
be very proud of what he's done enabled
to enable this conversation and to see
the changes that we're now seeing
and do you anticipate other qriket
boards around the world will have a
similar reaction to what you have seen
from the ecb in in the united kingdom
well i think everyone is watching what's
happening in england so of course there
are serious questions being asked about
the ecb and whether the ecb intervened
when they should have and have done all
they could have to
make sure that cricket is the safe space
that it ought to be so i think there are
real questions being asked about the way
the ecb has conducted themselves and
that's important that we improve the
regulator for the support for the sport
and that we see
positive changes implemented elsewhere
so i certainly hope that this is just
the beginning of what is the necessary
change that we need for qriket